what a birdie madoff sylvia plath the TV
show friends and Amanda Knox have in
common according to a new book they can
all help us understand why our
interactions with strangers often go so
wrong
the new book is titled talking to
strangers what we should know about the
people we don't know in it best-selling
author Malcolm Gladwell looks at the
harmful impact of not understanding
other people and how we can improve
Malcolm Malcolm joins us now good
morning thank you morning here I think
we should begin by defining stranger I
mean our were strangers we said hello in
the green room oh yeah yeah what is a
stranger in your view I mean anyone
outside of your immediate circle of
family and friends you know the point of
them to central arguments of the book is
that strategies that work really well
with people who are intimate to us don't
work so well with people who are outside
of our circle we need to understand that
they say the case of Sandra bland woman
in Texas pulled over ends up committing
suicide in prison a few years ago that
it's a case study in what can happen
when we fail to read strangers
appropriately how so yes so this was one
of those one of that string of very
high-profile cases a couple years back
of confrontations between
african-americans and police officers
and it is the it's the reason for the
book I have like many people heard about
that case was incredibly moved by it and
wanted to write a full explanation of
what happens how can a conversation
between a normal police officer and a
young woman coming from a job interview
you know middle-class Texas town in the
middle of the day how can it go so badly
awry that the woman ends up in prison
and then ends up committing suicide a
few days later and so I wanted to sort
of go through all of the ways in which
we can mistreat each other
what are the what are the mistaken
assumptions we carry around with us what
are the what are the are there tools
that were using to make sense of
strangers that aren't up to the task
you don't write about race in that
indirection though which which surprised
me I don't because it's implicit I mean
of course that confrontation was about
race but what I what I wanted to do was
to take the conversation one step beyond
because I feel like in this country
sometimes when we say that something's
racial it becomes an excuse to do note
to do nothing more you say oh the cop
was a racist and then you say well what
how do you prevent that in the future
how do you change someone's heart and my
point is there is a way to understand us
on a deeper level
yeah you said Sandra bland was in
criminal it wasn't a criminal she was
just very upset yeah you go point by
point the interaction between Sandra and
the cop people have to read that to get
to that because we've got so many things
in this book I like what you say about
the truth default theory yeah which is
so I hadn't thought about it until you
put it that way yeah explain what that
means mouth this is an idea from a
really brilliant psychologist named Tim
Levine who argues that he was concerned
with this problem that many
psychologists have been with concerned
with for years which is human beings are
not good at detecting lies we're
terrible at it
we think we're good at it we're not and
the question is why there's all kinds of
theories and his explanation I think is
the most convincing and he says it's
because we have a default to truth that
human beings as part of our essential
nature are trusting machines and that
when we talk to someone our assumption
is you are being sincere you are telling
me the truth and it takes a lot of
evidence to save me out of that default
position is that why you say
face-to-face interactions aren't helpful
well they are helpful they're
problematic I mean I think we greatly
overestimate how much information we can
gather from a face-to-face interaction
for this very reason among other things
because we weird we're very trusting and
also we jump to all kinds of conclusions
about from what you talk about the Brock
Turner case we just said the Stanford
swimmer harmless encounter on a dance
floor ended up a crime the reason why
this this story in particular is so
important it's about the role that
alcohol plays and people don't
understand yeah alcohol especially if
you're blind drunk changes who you are
yeah yeah I wanted to do that's deep in
the book I'm starting to talk about what
are the kinds of things that can impair
our ability to conduct this very
difficult negotiation between strangers
because these kids go to parties to meet
strangers they go to parties to meet
strangers and I think we have
underestimated just how it's more than
toxic it's that the presence of alcohol
in a conversation between two strangers
changes each party's sense of themselves
the decisions
make it can turn ordinary people into
criminals I mean is think and I think
that there is a particularly younger
generation there are they are they have
a I think a cavalier attitude towards
alcohols dangerous and we need to
address that we we need to meet
strangers we don't live in a village
anymore you're gonna constantly
encounter people that you don't know on
a daily basis if we're getting it wrong
right now how can we get it more right
how can we be better at this yeah so the
last part of the book is concerned I
take this specific example of how police
behave and because that that's one of
the most consequential that's a
profession by its very nature is about
people talking to strangers police
officers are required to how can we help
them do a better job and that's and I
think that is a really crucial question
and I talk in the book about how we need
to give police a lot more I mean to be
far more selective in how we use
proactive aggressive police power we
need to use it only in those situations
where there is a high degree of
probability that criminal behavior is
taking place right Malcolm Gladwell
thank you for being with us this morning
talking to strangers is on sale tomorrow